yes this thing needs to be on the chat
yeah
you
arrey we're live
welcome everybody we're gonna do this
thing today all right we got quite a lot
of people here I guess we're just on
youtube today
so hey Aditya hey do all the network I'm
feeling great today feeling great
I made it somebody with bishop at night
today so essentially I'm the greatest
chess player in the world and I'm here
to crush people today so yeah I like
what I'm seeing so far we got lots of
long time I'm gonna pick the longest
challenge I see right now cuz I'm not
sure if the tech side is ready wow it's
too big for my screen can you see it
Danny on the board Wow
yeah we have some tech problems but
we'll solve it live I'll make a move
here oh that looks good for you but if I
go up and down it does so they can't
even see me then all right well fix it
out live we'll do it all live and how do
I play my my wimpy system I'm trying to
play the wimpy system here yeah yeah I'm
a Wimpy chess player so you play I don't
know can you guys hear me
I don't know I see voices they can see
my voice okay thank hey from Canada hey
from Liberia Wow
is that the optimal feeling for
everybody
what's the username to challenge st.
Louis chess club well yeah again you
know I'll figure it out hey there I am
wow how exciting you can see the times
well you can see a lot of stuff check
can't resist a check all right you can
hear me good yeah yeah how is everybody
today also remind me not to play D three
might somehow lose a piece somehow so
I'm gonna castle
right so we have some random chess
position I'll try to get the bishops
just east of you guys in Louisville good
to have you Brandon mayor what is going
on today it resists a check checks are
impossible to resist and I have one
right now so you can imagine the
temptation I'm feeling I also could take
this thing well the temptations are are
limitless here if I want to keep my
bishops I had to go back here which semi
traps my queen so feel like I'm playing
kind of like a doofus but that's typical
right jester
good to have you I'm intending d3 night
out before hope nothing bad happens in
the mean time based on the fact that my
queen could have a better square I have
a six minute one second game waiting Oh
fantastic yeah the longer the games the
less I have to play that's what I'm into
getting it out
he's starting a check that doesn't seem
to do anything to me so continue by
executing my plan here don't know if
it's any good but I'm gonna do it if it
goes here I was locked in my bishop
perhaps I get this square I'm gonna hope
for the best
okay if he takes I can take back either
way I'll take you back this way so now
still I have a little square joined
slightly off camera by the great post
this is not now post Tek some fish up a
little bit
text a bishop like a little guy oh yeah
maybe I'll put a rook here but
ultimately there goes tonight at the
super optimal time I only got to tell
you what that is not one percent sure
what my opponents doing not sure why I'm
moving so fast either we have plenty of
time we could sit here I just don't want
to lose on time like usual Danis
beautiful gun oh yeah pins gun but I
have more bishops until this nice move
yeah was meant to do something to
prevent that what could you do I take
his name we'll take some we're good you
could sack your stuff yeah you think I'm
assuming Knights gonna take oh oh it was
a little shocking yeah it's nice a
poorly placed but they're covering a lot
of these important squares after Queen
c7 does really yeah we're on me seven
calculating calculating right now I know
okay I don't know what you do one of
these calculations streams
just like nothing well hoping to keep
this guy here forever kind of waiting
for him to move this submission moved my
queen from this area can he play 95 the
trade your your beautiful night they
love ya get rid of it get his night off
see for my muff destroy him
hey supernova he might check you where
oh oh no oh no oh no that guy's yeah
yeah you're too strong whoever said that
yeah yeah not playing that wow to play
that guy Wow
Queen to somewhere else yeah we're
playing people that strong well thank
you challenges are just coming left to
right have you seen a dilemma lords my
chest really chest profile oh yeah I was
there when he wrote it yeah yeah yeah
people have asked about it he's really
not playing this ever should i play here
myself let's spend three minutes
calculate now just do it whoa yeah
translator we had different ideas yeah
there's no way I can highlight oh I gave
him the score that's what he was waiting
for Oh your dad lured me in you lost he
lured me in you done but just but yeah
you know that all right well that's
interesting so what about the in-between
move 95 what are we gonna do you're just
gonna get pieces in
it's a little weak it's a little weak
the scores a little weak he attacks my
rook guys do stronger spawn maybe
hanging though one way to find out you
could be my twin but bored in a
different timeline born in 1988 and no
idea when Darren nationally play some
Cecilia
all right I'm on it this is a request I
can do oh yeah that guy who said Queen
h2 is only 14 that's just wrong yeah a
lot of people to avoid playing today all
right
not a brilliantly coordinate my Brooke
let's Bishop and they win do you think
drunk lifeguards are gonna play today
just a moment just a moment at the step
I don't know if people know the story
but uh yeah my brother's account he's
meeting me like you know once in the
last couple years or whatever but yeah
yeah he played the other day but it
turns out it was Danny pranking me on
the stream playing under my brother's
alias mean stuff
your brother's also beaten my comer a
few times yeah like you know Mike's not
practicing anymore I mean I was playing
don't seem same story yeah I don't know
if Mike knows I think he does I mean I
could I could have played better myself
I just well yeah but it's funny yeah
what's your rating what's your what's
your feed a rating just go by whichever
is higher
okay then I'm 1978 okay well there you
go grandmasters only care about your
feed a rating anyway
you just strict yeah don't don't mention
the USDF oh okay all right now to put
these pieces some good squares wherever
those may be let me go here
hopefully due to lots of pins I'll be
able to play here at some point open
Sicilian as far as I'm concerned it's
the only way to do this is silly and
open it up hope you win yay I got one
fan
where do you see your friends he said he
hopes I'm with him
he's a fan looks like this lots of
pending going on so what if he takes
your with your guy with the Queen tell
you get back women if he takes your rook
that's it oh well I said the thing with
your queen right well maybe you won't
see it and hopefully it's not watching
this dream oh but maybe you did blunder
like this maybe maybe if I come yeah
yeah a ray-ray no take on f7 and there
are 95 I have 590 535 oh gosh
I see the pin come on dude you see the
pin he sees the pin well then beat me
who cares
I was trying to lose all my games which
pin I don't know but he sees it oh it
means so for discovery going on slowly
warming up here 1,400 to 1,600 slowly I
see a letter oh right I get wedding
night f3
what are we starting a blemish what's
happened it's been a while since I'm
doing this I feel like I kept us at 2000
or something we have a hard time getting
that goes I thought you were right yeah
I thought you left at 2000 yeah yeah I
guess I had left I wasn't here for it
yeah I did it and I don't have her I
just dream so many things no days I
think
very wimpy system no I mean oh it must
have been no Mike only plays bullet it's
the Dutch defense an instant win no
instant lose yeah just taking the cue
he could have anyone went but hooray for
us he didn't see it Jonathan a sharp or
slow chess player kind of a dull slow
slowly sharp I'm slowly getting rest
here how do you do this yeah is he check
mated yet no yes some kind of prepping
for me my big match on April 12th
against Caleb did bear but oh yeah I
forgot that public yeah yeah yeah public
knowledge I'm just I'm working on the
trailer this is gonna be good
it's gonna be great good promo video
good so I've yet to open the files
though you get to open the files there
there are my desktop there in the to do
folder okay so as April 12th
so like April yeah 11th great you should
be able to see them oh yeah maybe that
midnight alright someone wants the whole
in gamut so I shouldn't try to play it
my truck g1 in this position that
happens I'll just push your Jeep on
Preston sometimes does it
what is your strange addiction' answer I
have a new addiction these days yeah
yeah kind of embarrassing so I should
tell you if I lose a game so that's your
punishment if you if you lose the game
we got to know your strange addiction oh
yeah okay really
I'll just turn on their life there's
stockfish really yeah I'll tell you
Darrin Ashley you what's your what's
your name you beat me any game I'll tell
you I have won no oh he isn't you is it
anybody yeah if I lose a game I'll tell
you okay it started I have a new
addiction as of yesterday I did
something yeah most people be
embarrassed but as Danny and I even
discussed today people have no shame
anymore so in America in our country
right yeah yes so there's no shame so
I'll tell you what I did yesterday I
think it was yesterday
well at least pretend for the streamer
how much can one reasonably expect to
improve in a year depends on where you
are what your what your level is and how
much time you put in like if you're some
kid then like tremendously 500 points a
thousand points you know something
ridiculous but you know I mean a good
year is it's one to two hundred points
for most people that'd be like just a
tremendous year yeah or any improvement
you know going up you know I mean if I'm
if you're already at a pretty decent
level and you're like maintaining I've
been going up 20 points would be a big
improvement depends it depends on where
you're at
[Music]
it's nothing like that dueling network
nothing like that that's also wrong it's
not that no that's nothing horrible it's
just as I was doing it yesterday I said
what I'd be embarrassed if people
figured this out yeah I'm curious now I
am not checkers sit no traders
checkers is the fascinating game I wish
more people played they never play they
also don't play go America our weed we
sure we're playing here hopefully this
guy complex hey why are we treated
traitor I thought it was gonna maybe
play night before I don't know but maybe
you did some really deep calculation
here maybe maybe yeah maybe the Queen
somewhere off I'll just get out of there
no it's not that flare not that
1,700 yeah it's quite a feat I think he
is saying he fell to 1,700 back and
Kessel this way that's where I want to
be Oh in two years old
okay so whatever they playing this well
just the way we planned it what's the
problem oh there's one from 1900 to 1800
after I watched just less of this
hopefully not my but could be if you
want to go from 19 to 1800 my god well I
got a series for that it's that's
because that's what I've done that was
that's my that's my level getting to
1900 and going back to 18 that's where
I'm at right now they'd all changes when
I take on mr. Caleb Denby also I'm
losing no huh no whatever because it's
all part of losing I can't count
I'm losing cuz I'm a bad player and I'm
not focused you're up two minutes
you win it's over yeah yeah yeah I mean
we'll win but that's I mean well yeah
what are you thinking about my Queens
hanging take my queen oh yes a weed you
thinking about in between move I'll
check what's the problem my life my
stuff you became twenty seven sixty five
and four months from 875 dad and yet
I've never heard about you so cheater no
I mean just in general it if you guys
are busy people doing busy people stuff
I mean I'm Italian I think it's by Mary
Queen I know but if you move like every
that was right yeah doesn't matter over
there's no increment or something I just
keep playing the moves I guess so
nope no increment yeah yes he might be
in trouble
take this thing array
at some point if we reach very desperate
times
I might have to you know really try to
avoid telling you please play it all
night addiction
well I can't play anybody good now cuz I
need to you know wow I got my clean back
right whoa yeah alright I think at that
point he was just trying to get the game
over with alright but thank you
chess fouled you were beating me yes so
far are two games I've been losing twice
yes rook g1 didn't work out that's weird
oh just addict how casual no you got a
play everybody wants to play on the list
you want to play I don't even see them
Colosseum yeah no it's not real it's my
car a real person should be here too all
right
this is a conspiracy theory my comer
reddit post yeah the question of how to
like you compared to it depends on if
you're like a kid and you have time or
for an old man
you own the time anymore
all right Abdel where are you at you
almost accepted my challenge dang
alright well we'll do it again we'll see
if we can find you
is this you plane 1800 no we're going up
the line but I do not know you're all
about it yeah I know I should mix it up
yeah this has not been working out I
feel like maybe this is just your so
Caleb can't see your prep is that what's
going on here
or is this your prep I think I might
give up on this we're going we're going
back to Y Kramnik play it Knight f3 and
you saw my last two games right well
just some play before you're right
you've never been more right we took
your paw and you're dead he lost upon
you blundered upon hey it's tennis the
road that's telling me it's down the
pond this is their race or fun as long
as we play lots and lots and lots of
theory get back here
get back here with you know how to do it
I'll turn off the camera not as fast as
I can turn it off well not really being
lazy I'm not gonna go that far we go
these leper you're welcome hey
Despereaux came back in here you might
help me lose a game did you hear what
you heard admins if I if I lose again my
new my new embarrassing addiction you
might not want to know in which case you
should exit the building immediately
yeah all right yeah go do anything else
whatever whatever dance aru's got
aha my point is take stakes I think I
can take with my night my Bishop singing
but then his bishop would be hanging
judging having prepping for this match
yeah yeah I will one day one day we'll
have some press are you yeah are you
gonna ever gonna do an openings class
livestream openings class yeah keep
talking about is it gonna happen after
yeah I can't give it away now yeah I
can't give it right now the wimpy system
I'm doing a lecture on it it's a system
right I don't know where the flash is
that just a reverse hippo or something
dude it's it's really good you're gonna
want to stay tuned is it one partner
like five-part series it's like we're
not gonna stop
we're just once you start playing like a
wimp you can't stop what was your
longest opening series is a semi-soft
semi-soft only what all right arrow easy
let's play to not lose just above
anything else listen I play to even try
to win or have any advantage let's just
played in that loose we have the better
Bishop you went okay easy perfect
just keep chilling out let's just keep
chill it out does not commit to anything
here just super safe super safe
look about here actually let me a memo
why oh okay but let's do a little prep
first marshal tak Lessing what's amazing
yeah the only problem is to to do a
lecture like that I would need just some
time I only want to do it if I actually
have legitimate amount of time to
prepare something and right now we've
just been in tournament mode tournament
tournament tournament tournament so uh
he's prepared you know works no oh it
doesn't
yes mr. banner six all right something
keeps getting ready for this move strong
that was about doubling every what about
house is sick so I'm really recovering
just I'll be a little nasally today just
apology just inhibition
here cuz maybe he won't see it doesn't
stuff you gotta calculate your own chess
player where's he going here
I've never lost with King's gambit yeah
can be a good weapon
things can bit you about that lifestyle
I'm actually surprised you haven't
played the Kings gambit Dennis well
because you play the Danish are you used
to the whole goal is to not lose you
draw people whatever should I take this
oh my gosh
oh wait so no time there's no oh my gosh
wait there's no time there's no time ah
yeah yeah why is this a three-minute
game what's happening here you're
winning
easily you don't need any time to prove
it
yeah I'm getting up cool I'm just fixing
this shot perfect didn't listen so here
we go right what's the torturous yeah
the whole goal today is to know this
hopefully this doesn't work
what's my bishop out here I'm stupid
okay I'm actually I'm gonna make sure
the Johnny's not dying because thanks
for not flagging me yeah it was never my
intention
oh no no Millis wait I have to take this
way no I'm gonna lose cuz I'm better yes
here I have to go here I don't know
yeah yeah we'll see what happens am i
listening a little bit I'm watching what
you guys are typing take this player
seriously okay moving
you still haven't challenged said your
new username we're on the HS our name is
st. Louis chess club so maybe you can
actually put the link and spam it in
there so people can see the think you
think a challenge
take some care here
got to take some care here
worried about this thing yeah maybe but
here still my next move why didn't you
play might have hung upon I had no
problem since I know it's moving here
Wow you can just do that
dang it just take him okay I trust in us
the real
Oh part of the plan God takes back
however you guys play the game urgently
Denis once your next blitz bounty oh
yeah yeah oh I have a lesson with him
today
I guess yeah five bucks yeah he found it
probably an April done yeah I think we
have like three events in April done
scheduled we have Jonathan's we have
bliss bounding I guess theoretically and
we have my comers yet to be announced
project whoa I don't know about this
whoa carefully I'm just saying he might
have one I guess we all might I guess we
all might have secret projects I played
that move fast like I know what's going
on
which one this bend there's two of them
that are pants
you devil dual pin Quadro this work
how do numbers work yeah we have a thing
just keep attack making him attack me
more
oh my clean as much as I can I don't
know what go around a bit I don't think
anything could go wrong with the typical
Plan B down upon for some reason
I don't know he's gonna lose night it's
gonna tack my night
this guy's gonna go somewhere no mine i
stacked yeah and then he's gonna
maneuver it to some square that's better
and I'm like is that a double techno
protected just guys good maybe no
failing the beans on what I've done
might be better yeah no certainly you
should probably play love you too hard I
should Caleb I should play Caleb you oh
yeah based on this based on my my
brilliant chess abilities what I do it
impressed you I saw a piece was the
factors yeah yeah I love stuff that was
amazing I love stuff I was truly
impressed Wow come on rook here no no
tanking my thing one time would be
enough enough
[Music]
Wow I have a check yeah tech things once
know what I do when I could find
something useful to do with you all
right
you won't like you know deep maneuver
when they can't just can't do it manage
one make it make moves we'll just both
keep making moves
go here are you gonna take it
no no maybe I should but I'm not going
to yeah take what okay I'll take
anything you say I trust you I know but
I do true love story yeah yeah random
night ops they can think go like this so
people think I'm calculating stuff you
are give off the appearance tactical
wizard then on the rim is grim oh hey I
did what I wanted to do like a million
years ago you know I'm almost starting
to think your pardon gimme you check me
uncheck
it is needed
let's one go down through here for
insightful commentary Dennis do you want
to join us
you want to sit down mr. mumbles okay I
miss you though look just some random
move
what's the next what's the next idea
here she showed up yeah in some temple
okay sometimes I think I make phone
calls huh take slightly more time to
collect my thing
check me my check you hopefully there's
no way there's no increment than UN yeah
people are seeing some high level stuff
today ah second wow Johan was thank you
for the game sir it was a good game that
was fantastic stuff no I was interesting
I think he was the highest rated guy on
here by quite a bit so I'm ray my secret
is safe for another game SIPO a chance
to force me to spill the beans on my new
secret addiction Gus has an important
message I don't know what it is but he's
got one
yeah if you want to see bad chess but
somehow pulling out victory after
victory this is where it's that you know
just is that all about good moves a lot
of it is just that special something
that helps you win games you know that's
very important it's not actually about
being good having any skill it's just
about having that special something how
do we join you come to lead chess and
challenge st. Louis chess club yeah I
don't have to sign in to spend it down
hooray is this your favorite opening
nowadays French how could I lose that
how could I lose the goal is to not lose
I'll draw anybody Zippo
I'll Josip oh okay
Wow okay he went that way I go this way
that's the safest put this thing here
but there's nothing to trade well isn't
your bishop on d3 so we can trade you
just feel that was more funny
yeah he's funnier and better at chess so
I located MB that is oh man yeah yeah
bands so that's an important message I
take I won't think about it though was
this that's a five minute game we can
think there's a better person to me
better chess player speaks better
English than me it's probably like third
or fourth language it also plays a lot
of video games from ready it's probably
better do get rid of me yeah hearthstone
stuff
hooray another trade getting closer to
not losing it so John why you ignore me
I need chess I'm a chess addict am i
ignoring you and you've been talking in
the chat if I'm not reading whatever
brilliant insightful commentary you've
added to our lovely discussion here yeah
I was thinking didn't see it
I'm Caleb Denby addict Wow you can check
maybe somehow please don't check maybe
should win this at some point you should
try to prevent any counterplay here it
looks like I got everything covered for
now but if I went upon and everything's
covered I'll be doing well you know
should be able to not lose this which is
the name of the game today just ask this
guy to leave for just a second
and then checked all over buns pick up
this guy and all these guys looks like
it's over every move I take a pond
should be good for me make way for this
I like my chances here you went there
go
there he goes go go getting close
getting very close Nexus here or here
probably doesn't make my night and then
are you still winning if you hanged if
you hang tonight I'll try I think so no
let's find out let's find out together
I'll try to hang my night we'll leave
this one so tricky it's too tricky yeah
hang all my Knights
does it work out yeah well I tried yeah
sure just make whatever do you think you
got attempted me might still be been
inked up one point yeah it's a weird
point to be up though but as you've seen
him for most of the game so that's good
prim take my stuff that's a good plan it
worked
yeah no no I should have listened to you
where everywhere where am i winning
right there which one that one for sure
hopefully under promote to get Knights
well I did a Bishop Knight checkmate
today so do it again
well I can't lose right so I should I
don't have to reveal any straight the
three nights checkmate
that old yo yeah yeah yeah okay that's
true story what it is it's a true story
yeah I bet you couldn't do it again
we have a colleague who's been I guess
practicing for a year which i think is a
true story and he's able to do it still
it's a tough mate I'm sorry I need to
pay attention to who I'm playing so that
Mikael tall guy still says he yes yes it
goes sound kilt all yeah right there
there you go all right this is a 1900
look that last game at one that was
actually like I was all these women
anyone that was a nice feeling no
checkmate with 3/9 is that a thing you
know use that secret right are you
always gonna pretend he doesn't know
that for the Caleb yeah that's how I
want to embarrass
do it okay bet ah perfect
there you go for this guy go back to bed
cuz I'm moving out of many secrets and
I'm somebody helping not to reveal any
today so as long as I don't lose my
secrets should be safe with me
what's happening here I don't know this
land what am i playing Oh like weird
different stuff oh yeah
as Danny suspects trying so hard to
avoid any preparation or maybe this is
your preparation am i preparing for the
first time actual how far does this go
boom boom boom
I guess you won yeah you won yeah this
game I think you're winning so that begs
that your Bishop can sag on our 7-under
for that's
I love a good drum I'll tell anybody in
the world today is the Alaska variation
good oh yeah
are there many Laska variations wonder
would opening is talking about yeah
everything's good although things are
good no not the bank oh you just lose
well it's good against me you just walk
nobody played it against me up today so
today no it's happening here check I can
never resist I just like checking people
it's kind of funny Bob about the book
you recommended it's well glad it's
going well for you oh you win well the
other way when you don't know what's
going on you can calculate and then you
give a chance of knowing what's going on
you can just play the move quickly No
thank you one I think the game's over
you won array a small positional success
it's bad but what's bad didn't go here
after the trade Queens it's probably but
I don't believe it
take it once sure he had some idea oh
yeah
my tea is just not to lose so as long as
I don't lose I'm happy today it's a
pretty good idea yeah I'm up upon a
better position so my goal now is just
not to lose therefore not revealing any
of my deepest darkest secrets on the
street you guys a bill say Oh Caleb dead
bees there's always a chance that you'll
calculate incorrectly right I was very
careful with my wording I realize I said
you have a chance to understand what's
actually happening
yeah is that the real Caleb that's been
online my secrets today so I'm gonna
play the wimpy system in this system
it's not protecting this thing so much
you're gonna get checked all right go to
a bet square are you gonna take the
b-pawn or yeah poison oh no calculated
oh yeah I believe you do go here he
always calculates everything accurately
yeah first time lady Benko as black
well that just loses a bomb oh what a
great line
yeah I don't play the bank up but he
played against me you probably win
because they always was against it oh
you have an imaginary friend yeah Danny
but Ruka is it really just one though
there's a lot of voices it out when they
are there I don't want to talk about it
part of my deep dark secret
hopefully Caleb hasn't challenged us cuz
it'll be a match people want to see what
might I haven't not today now in deep
dark secrets are on the one Oh Caleb
wrote down a Wimpy system in his book I
think you just lost the match no that's
the thing I might play though so he like
an a-plus game probably he's rapping for
you know we should I don't want any
pathetic wimpy games in the book every
when we doing this thing yeah who's your
favorite just player from the Romantic
era they were all bad
what's your pet's there's morphe is the
best parties all right is this based on
just fine goals this is a checkmate yet
no array of what checkmate a raise it
never actually happens in real games
just make sure Caleb's not challenging
us doesn't what something except how
this person's in the chariot this is
Caleb challenge us we all know their
strengths though first not begs I would
play you because that's an amazing name
but that's casual do me casual no casual
no no what is the Romantic era this
person this is this a person they're
telling me to play this guy yeah yeah
that guy me whatever you beg enough
could this be the guy could just okay
there he is forced me to review all now
this is a three minute game three plus
one oh three plus one could this be the
guy that forces me to reveal my deepest
darkest secret pinned you you're dead
I'm dead
sorry
this is some deep stuff this is like
Tony rich yeah yeah
isn't it yeah what does he play he
didn't play this right away yeah this
Queen goes here and you check me yeah
that's mine yep you can just go here
that's the plan whatever you want take
that I'll take this
if you Castle witnessing events good
sanity talking to nobody
we all have our problems don't judge
Jonathan here here over here and just
hold this in - nothing in between
hopefully he can't take this I'll just
play here and just laugh and it doesn't
work for sure good doesn't hey Dennis
Monroe and speaking of spiraling into
insanity Dennis LaRue what is if you
come here if you see demo oh I think
it's in front of the camera he wanted to
cancel that way so I'll stop yeah all
right yeah but can you change it are we
is it official are we officially enemies
millions and millions of spectators
everyone knows you're my chess hero
you're my chess hero sarcastic
no no hold on one more time alone back
so no this is a streak we got help me
win cuz if I lose I'll have to reveal
you only my newest secret addict go
don't do that
oh no you're a winner yep and you're and
and you're my chess hero no sarcasm
you're my chess hero I'm gonna keep
saying it until it's 700 tricky stuff
going on there a lot of tricky stuff
just happened which way which way does
he want to castle I'm going whichever
way you actually wants to go you guys
only I knew you got this you're I know
you forced him over there yeah where his
house is broken yeah
killing a guy will go back yeah this guy
will go back let's go bring him back
book hangover attack a Pinto to eat five
bunnies
I don't know I have a bad feeling what
this game no you're doing great possibly
but I have a bad feeling you know doing
great isn't enough to win a chess game
don't you just have a feeling things are
not going right well I could have
anything to do with the fact that he has
three he has a million pawns in the
center like we detect won't you tell me
dude you're not gonna tell me these
kinds of something's dude I'm rated 1400
it doesn't register so like a second
half to her registers for you okay go go
yeah no it doesn't see I could tell
something that that's gonna move and I
don't want just addict to be the one to
force the addiction out of me
there's me it's just a decoy how do you
go where's he from
that's the way do you speak a little how
I do is add just adding zero perhaps I
don't speak Lithuanian checkmate
how dare you he's not leave me dude
don't stop check meeting me I can't do
that
please don't check baby please don't
check baby please don't check please
don't you're winning
really bad move but I'm really hopeful
it's a great really hopeful really
hopeful dude how how can this fail let's
go Bishop before I don't know only if he
played that five maybe yeah that sounds
like thinking thinking she's defense oh
yeah yeah yeah oh reading the base guy
it involves thinking okay you don't have
to think you just read what they say and
then like make fun of me no didn't you
see that ladies night stream you it
requires some thinking you need to like
make sure they're not horrible things
okay no they can it's all the physical
appearance or no that's fine but they're
sneaky these these Internet people's all
right so check me here should I sit here
deeply investigating whether or not play
fast you're gonna flag him take that guy
hey hey
I guess I easily could have gone to the
quarter pipe you wanted to show him that
your King is a man but look he just
could have hearing King is like I know
we just take any perpetual we see don't
lose the game
crazy man faster not there one out there
where'd you go you got a check here all
right
you went array pre-move rook b7 no so do
it now you can do it okay right
undefeated today is the guy on the right
what happened to him uh Anand is cool
his name is Anand friends yes I like a
nun Anand finaid I want to play a week
about sir that's a three minute though I
really shouldn't of all right well we
got little bits will do uh three more
games three more games I got three more
ma I believe in you French to Vince
mix it up Carol con is the French
defense ISM Thank You dong zhuo the
French defenses ugly cousin is what the
carrot is are you saying the guy on the
right is just a joke was just a joke guy
on the right that's not what they're
saying you know that stop being rude to
me that's Danny why haven't we changed
this Jonathan surance and enemy oh hey
yeah Jonathan's pain Don Jose I never
lose never lose as far as people know I
have no secret addictions they take me
on low rated soil perfect on your street
yes what's your name I'll play you
next-gen almost ninety is that your uh
handle on on whatever it is no my
comment was just a joke
and look I'm signed out for some reason
how did that happen dennis is cool yeah
three minute game a minute after like
four moves it's just a joke should be
the title of the stream oh yeah I'm
banning you well this is just a joke
what are we doing here serious chess
players you're the strongest a clay I
feel like you're supposed to play
tonight up six here with the idea of
something something and c5 is allowed
but someone doing it what does your mug
have in it honey it's not your addiction
it's a good guess but no it's just uh
real coffee I like it black I don't play
anything
Damon Matt won against the GM with Kings
gambit on it and he's so humbled that he
spelled the pronoun I with a lowercase
played the Johnathan Sean's a four game
recommended by a nine friends but you're
on record saying we're not friends is
that is that fair yeah I feel like
you're you you push me into a corner
yes enemy mortal enemies for life slash
the tires please don't fire me
do I need to slash your tires every day
yeah it's kind of weird that you're
still still kind of on the subject of
slashing tires every tires been slashed
since two three night check my favorite
it's no one chess related it's a non
chess related addiction it's a very fast
addiction spoiler alert checkmate game
has he done that you did this against
like Fritz or something yeah and he did
like oh no you were talking about flying
golden lion queen does it sound like I
think Danny was talking about and that's
but it sounds like him I feel like you
should finish this game now I am against
monster can you play the hey Kyle from
streaming right now what's up
yeah okay sounds good
did let me know he's up to hmm do you
love to trade differentiation I Castle
this way then yeah he has no
LightSquared bishop you'll never check
me you raced at each other cool
superiority are you an expert on the
slide
oh yeah yeah no well I know that you
played a Carol con but it looks like a
French but how do I not lose I don't
need to win I have nothing to prove
against this guy he fatally yeah break
well this might be strong but I trust
your judgment and I'm gonna listen to
you why did you do that he could play d5
open the file okay I trust you yeah
isolate you strategically one you sturdy
yeah yeah you have you've isolated as
Queen spawn some other stuff you did it
you did it you're amazing why am I on
the roads are not losing here I believe
so
Trey the b7 pawn I don't know if this is
a good move or not but it's like I'm
it's great you got we're gonna flag them
and we're gonna not lose our feeling I'm
not gonna like calculate some like
taking this should probably wind stuff
just gonna not lose that's the mood
theme of the day so why not look d4 - oh
don't worry about ya Bishop f6 and it
just works it just works I trust your
judgment
oh no that's even you know yours nobody
said f6 buy some that's what you meant
no I'm man Bishop f6 that's also I think
you're you know you're alive and well
here you're doing good okay cuz if it
takes that clear okay yeah also
something just back right in England
yeah okay you calculated it off dude
I teach tactics for a living
all right all right matin - can anybody
write her a thank-you powerful fat sir
that another Jonathan this guy wanted to
play - but casual get out oh oh my
strange addiction yeah yeah yeah that's
who people want you to play this well on
a day like this white know that we must
how long will you guys be playing listen
one more uh-oh it's the Dutch gonna take
me down oh this is some random new
account somehow managed to get one game
in probably what do you start out did
they win or lose that's important
knowledge starts - you're like 1,200
yeah so this person probably won one
game even I don't know what they're up
to be like the 13th to be Caleb Denby we
got to play here God play well got to
play well here's the plan here's the
plan I can break it open and we're
playing serious stuff now serious stuff
against my strange addiction Caleb won't
even look at a Dutch here's the plan
night 2 here basically g4 break it up
the year I mean real stuff this is real
chess we're playing now but we're joking
around against my strange addiction yeah
I think that they just made this is it
yeah they made it because you were
talking about your Oh your secret
addiction you it's really strange to
really strange from man to have this
okay both yeah yeah yeah dad yeah this
okay
well I'm just I like your breathing and
thinking well this and this everything
is under attack
it's all falling apart can I start doing
commentary in Spanish like my best
imitation of let's go very serious okay
focus I get some strange so we need
pepper in all 100 yeah that will get a
great team
check yeah go back h3 g4 guess what side
don't need to worry about this I don't
know he's gonna go this way to know this
guy where's he going where's going
where's it going oh I see
okay Catholic Queen side oh sure
so I guess he's going here no he's
trying to trying to get me good
don't get me good leave me alone what's
up is that what's up calculation baedal
this is the most not losing move I can
find Queen G for ya and just do it okay
I trust you yeah that's really good take
with the fun but I trust your judgment
you're up on time please I have did if
he takes Queens and I go here sorry I
drew this arrow so in my mind I'm like
oh this thing's open but now we're
focusing okay yeah you're doing great
yeah yeah take back I can't play a five
this is great yeah and maybe moves the
Queen's business yeah how much let's
play that Evans gambit let's not play
the skull at me guess the back of your
computer's screen yeah okay yeah yeah
I'm gonna start advertising the put your
name back there five bucks Dennis that's
right send five dollars to me and I'll
put your advertisement do I want to
break now can I break now well I know
what I have to take back with a queen
there or something and you give him a
four no I know no no no so I can take
with my name cuz I'll have this check
okay
okay oh he has Bishop f4 check it at
various points does he not where's it
for okay time to move this thing was I
wrong maybe I shook yeah who knows I
think he looks like he yeah he's not
doing we're doing great great just not
anywhere becae flat great well you're up
you're up 30 seconds you're not doing
great if you think for another 15
seconds see if he's got the guts to take
me I don't think he does
I think that's a worthy try giving the
pawn away there okay yeah no no no after
it okay so all the trading yeah I'm down
upon I knew that long game - maybe I
should think more no okay I've been
waiting service I'm in a winning
position anonymous who are you tell us
your screen name on me chest and maybe
we'll accept your channel this and one
more oh oh we probably declined your
challenge because it wasn't rated what
we're only accepting rated challenges
okay I played against the GM and I okay
stop calculating we both know neither
one of us can calculate what do you
think I'm playing a corresponding game
which is just count again but after the
counter Gannet both sides refused to
take any material whatsoever
yeah I'll be right there okay I'm out of
here all right
the front desk is burning down so we're
gonna be down to pawn here I don't see I
don't see too many tricks for me this
guy he's playing - well - well for me
stop playing so well I don't want to
play a guy that plays as well but I have
a little trick here I think I think I
have a little trick now
yeah soft on my trick that's all I had I
had one trick one trick pony
it's guys too strong
I have to say I'm not a fan of how
strong my opponent in this a little bit
too strong for me
see you Shane you got a good bit I
suppose
this is a threat yet
must be a threat now right
he takes that trading they pick up your
Bishop and then what's happened to get
that endgame hopefully I believe this
guy in this guy races come on tell me I
have a threat for once
okay
let's go let's go one day this has to be
a threat come on how long can your queen
be sitting here and I don't have any
threats how long can that last
my strange addiction is still up a pond
we're battling here I'm starting to get
some pressure take him down
okay
go here but probably this diagonal would
be a bad one to open up if I take you
how do you how do you protect your guy
give me my pawn back I shouldn't lose
losing is the idea
winning is irrelevant so I'm just taking
this little bit better maybe I should
predict this whatever but if we traded
to this end game opposite bishops should
be a draw at least I might win a time
there's a lot of time in this game
though okay my part is trying to win
that's slightly upsetting
go here you cut off this king
should be able to
avoid losing here that's the big goal in
life found a hacker no I don't think we
ever think we have a hacker on our hands
we're not gonna lose guaranteed
guaranteed not lost here guaranteed not
loss go away
hey Gautama thing in the best yeah
it's weird that he didn't throw the
chicken but I defeated this guy in two
minutes who Oh
Aditya Shawn looks like a cheat this
guy's play as well for 1,300
yeah he's played one game though we
don't know this guy's real strength he
opened the engine I don't know I don't
know what this person is actual
readiness I don't really expect anything
our last game or you have my trap yeah
jack oh stop mate here
can't be done whew yeah that was a tough
battle you know that was a tough battle
dude we're not gonna learn about one
more child one more chance alright you
get one last chance now to watching some
bold people what pays me princess
whatever the highest rated player is and
not this player now oh yeah yeah well I
hope drunk lat John lifeguard might not
actually be King tracer high or drunk
lifeguard who is obviously Danny with an
engine or this guy that legitimately
should be it he's been asking like a lot
yeah yeah let Fabio new draw here for a
battle yeah yeah this is it not a mess
here you go buddy
mm guys here's your chance oh never mind
come on this is it I'm a man and good
game Derek so that's the good game okay
this is it I'll play the highest rated
player I can find King chaser Oh play
some opening I always lose ended
take it you blundered upon an any blood
right o0 here oh this is not my son
place just but nobody plays before movie
go away there you go I'm trying to play
more like blaze he's drunk he's played
and raided event now that guy Tony
shouldn't he throws good chess events
for children why didn't she take on d40
ideas of what's going on right now ok
gang up I was doing my my tactics on
chest temple yesterday and blaze came up
to me and you know everything's not all
that high on that side it's like
seventeen hundred any we had some
seventeen hundred puzzle I've been
looking at it for like two minutes
and then oh no no no it's over the night
moves away and I'm lost but then just
Knight takes any ones and place came up
to me after I've been thinking about my
tactic for about two minutes and he said
hey dad why don't you put your queen
here in attacks rook and a bishop you
told me the story about now or do you
fight yeah I know what they haven't
heard it I know so yeah yeah my son's
almost too strong for me now these days
Kings chasers too strong for me these
days
anyways too strong apologize in advance
to JK Duda and Fabiano draw wanna you
guys are not going to get played today
yeah Evans gave it to strong for me if
you don't know anything which is what
we're witnessing here it's very strong
can i outplay a 2000 rated player down a
piece yeah that's exciting
and yes compensation duties you're gonna
you got this wow it's really friendly of
you I'm glad I'm glad you're here for me
yeah all right but the dramas building I
defeat you with the Evans gambit nobody
knows sometimes you wonder all your puns
I've always admired you inside of you as
a friend
Thanks yeah it's too bad that we wound
up being enemies I don't know what it
brought it on probably just my best my
desperate need to make jokes constantly
something clearly happened today it's
upset yeah oh yeah I know that's right
the world needs to know
Danny Machuca is a bughouse cheater one
oh here now I see your point
you're gonna go try to trick Queens
you're a big Queen trader no Queen trade
under any circumstance
even if said bug
[Music]
it's all coming clear to me now
yeah do you want to tell the story or
shall I really shouldn't last forever
but
but Joe you might play there cuz then he
can sneak his Queen in this pond spend
how do I take it
anymore sky everybody's got me frazzled
these days is it just just you come on
he stopped me it was I don't think I see
that I have a threat I didn't even see
it until the people in power are always
trying to keep the truth
this is it yeah yeah yeah probably a
little bit worried think I can let this
end well for me
are you trying for a for a I'm just
trying to do yeah
I'm just gonna take and plane all your
now you lost another client swear I
don't know I just it was plus one for a
point yeah gonna have to go back maybe
he can then you can do one of these did
anyone see someone versus Magnus calls
and six two week on it's too weak
let's mode let's mode activate it there
we go here we go here we go
this isn't working I'm doing
no I'm the where ISIL irked yeah yeah
this is quite bad this is quite bad the
only mm you got you blundered this pond
and sound it seems well because yeah
okay we're talking you can take you know
okay I don't I'm waiting for the if you
can hear me world yeah don't say bad
things about alright you better turn the
sound down cuz I'm gonna have to reveal
huh yeah yeah it's dream tell us can you
guys actually hear us can you hear us
type in can you hear us now good yeah
well that's you guys actually hear us
how long were we muted buzz Kings Jay
sir
got it done in the end can they actually
hear us though they said if you could
mute us for a minute
I'm gonna tell my new secret
it's really only based off of some guys
comment so we'll chalk it up like it's
my new addiction but I did something
yesterday we'll just tell a little story
and we'll end the stream um that I
haven't done in a long time but it was
fantastic I'm now we only want to hear
Jonathan whatever Brandon Meyer get out
of here big time everybody ready for it
everyone wants tea people want to hear
it maybe they don't mean what chatroom
do you guys want to hear like an ever
weird thing Jonathan's gonna tell you
that he's addicted to okay oh shoot I
got a meeting right now I gotta go go
well don't you know you gotta tell us
the moment of truth we know we can heat
all the blenders learn how to spell well
can you hear me talk yeah they can hear
us okay well it was muted it was
definitely muted okay Mayer
all right yeah good for you Jonathan all
right okay you know let me confess to
you doing this if nobody else I'm
assuming nobody's listening you're a
friend you're a friend I've been labeled
as a friend yeah good friends listen to
other people when they just tell what
they're the kinds of things that they're
into in life you know ears
my ear is all yours or something all
right very thoughtful but yeah me I'm
big time in two baths
I'll have taken a bath there's a little
too much information that's I like
taking baths I gotta go now that's my
secret addiction doing this is weird
dude so yesterday I was you know I was
at home I don't want here anymore so
just take a bath please should we go
well I was asking I asked my wife her
you know some sort of bath balm or soap
or something we only had this little
pink snow queen I think we're Snow Fairy
it's called something like girly and
it's like unlock your inner princess
it's just some pink bubbly soap uh-huh
and you wanted value like your inner
princess no I just like bubble baths
it's my new secret addiction that dude
it's a hard-working family men
I deserve a bath you know 40 bubbles I
recommend it 40 mil I highly recommend
it industry thank you very much for
joining us and look Jonathan won't curse
this week yeah I guess I'm like hot my
blenders yeah what Oh what what are they
saying
Danny's not ending the stream use bad
bombs you gotta treat yourself sometimes
someone thought that you were addicted
to edamame but you want to talk to these
people see how they feel uh respects me
ten times more now yeah Wow see
sometimes you gotta let these things out
and then people will respect you for who
you truly are
it's all I wanted to use a bath bomb but
we didn't have it why you layin at home
was a little little thing princess so
refreshed
you look very refreshed yeah and I smell
like a princess so it feels good I
recommend it dance are sweet wow what a
Beth love I'm gonna take us out there
like a hot tub yeah yeah a lot of
support for taking baths all right I've
had enough of this thank you exactly you
thank you